hey guys I just got out of a meeting
with the intern class at vaynermedia
this year but what really ended up
happening was a complete manifesto to
anybody who's like 17 to 24 in the world
so if you are or know somebody who's 17
to 24 you need to watch this [ __ ] and
watch it four times
you got your prospectus
[Applause]
[Music]
great so you know I guess the thing that
I can open with is I think a lot about
this program and just internships in
general and I think that I've been
pretty vocal in the past for my content
standpoint of like how like I
unbelievably don't believe the ROI of
this internship is the skill set that
you're learning though I'm sure for some
of you you know especially knowing in
certain categories you know paid media I
feel very confident about and all of
them I do but there's clearly places
where you will learn skillsets
I'm sure you'll learn plenty on Team
Gary like we're proud of like what we're
good at but this has to be a huge big
game of like interpersonal relationships
it is like you're gonna cozy up with
each other cuz it's easy you're going
through the same [ __ ] right and it
creates a natural bond this is it's
imperative that you muster up whatever
extroverted DNA you have to just say
hello in the kitchen it's just
imperative it just you I can't explain
enough to you that there are 13 people
that work in this company right now then
in 19 years are gonna be the CMO so the
biggest companies in the world I don't
know what to tell you
like so as you can imagine if I'm even
half right the serendipity of one of
those people you know becoming somebody
you have a relationship with
disproportionately changes the course of
your professional career not to mention
the thing I'm proud of and lose some
sugar feeling this like from from a
culture and pet team and how we care
about like human stuff like there's the
professional aspect of like me being
right about that and you know you then
becoming way more advanced in your
career 12 years from now because you've
tagged along with Lisa or Johnny or
Susan as their careers progressed
there's just also the fact that a
shocking amount of people at vaynermedia
end up marrying each other becoming
singular best friends with each other
like this we have a very interesting
framework when it comes to human
dynamics that I think lends itself to a
ROI and so not every person is going to
be extroverted or as comfortable to like
roll up on somebody cold and say what's
up but I promise you there's very few
businesses on earth that it's safer than
here to do that and I couldn't push you
harder to do it elevators random
meetings you know going to you know
obviously at this point you probably
feel some comfort level with the person
above you or the people that are a
buying you asking them to create the
serendipity for you or bring you into
different rooms just to take a look or
you know your project management but are
curious about creative just being thrown
into a meeting like tasting tasting
things is the number one strategy in
your 20s you've made decisions about
what you're about and it's highly likely
you're wrong and when I say wrong the
holy grail of life professionally is to
love what you're doing and be good at it
you know there's a lot of people who
love what they do and they're okay at it
there's a lot of people that crush at
something but [ __ ] hate it you know
and the only way you'll know that is if
you taste more I was I was smiled when
I'm on this kick because I think about
oysters a lot so like I'm really into
them and like like I've gotten pretty
knowledgeable about them like west coast
East Coast like that kind of [ __ ] and
it's just so funny how many people have
decided they don't like oysters without
ever having them and that's how I think
about careers you think you're fin ops
but you're really strategy you think
you're strategy but you really account
you think you're project management but
you're really thin ops
and I think about that every day my job
at the top of this whole thing is to put
players in the position to succeed the
nature of where you are in your life
gives you more flexibility to do that
for yourself if you have the patience
and humility to go through the process
that's my spiel what can I answer who's
got questions like you can go super
narrow you can go very broad great we
approved that and what I think my
purpose is is to put my city on the map
I haven't so I learned there talking to
people outside of my community that
people are aware of it which was really
interesting because when you grow up in
that and you're part of that community
you don't really you don't see the value
in it and so as I've gotten older I
guess like couldn't your norm its my
norm and everybody looks like me that's
your norm right and so I guess like just
certain experiences that I went through
my dad was the first Arab Muslim
administrator of a high school in
Dearborn and he got a lot of
Islamophobia and like just hatred and
like hate speech in the media yeah that
made me really passionate about kind of
like controlling that narrative yes um
so we started a podcast yep and it's
kind of taken so like it's gotten a lot
of statewide attention and recently ABC
the ABC Nightline just reached out and
so now we're getting national attention
which is like a dream come true like I
honestly was crying all night last night
about it because they just happen
yesterday it's awesome I'm trying to
figure out how to continue using the
niche that we have because the news just
spreads like wildfire in my community
and that's what's helped us get that
attention but also so like using that
niche but not not relying on the niche
of the community to get that global
attention because that's at the end of
the day we want to be the ones telling
our stories because anyone who's talking
about Arabs and Muslims globally right
now aren't doing so from our perspective
of course representing us of course and
I kind of want to create a universe
we're the ones who were telling her
stories well that's called the Internet
you're not gonna create it I didn't
create it it's been created what people
don't understand is we're going through
cycles so we even if you think about it
at the highest levels like there's so
much more conversation today about
privacy right that nobody talked about
privacy eight years ago everything was
about to share everything this is just
pendulum swings to your point
right now just like Jews and Europe in
the 40s and 50s and african-americans
and the 50s 60s and said like these are
just moments in cultural time you you
know depending on how you see life you
there have the serendipity or the neck
or the unlock of being who you are
during this time when it is your
subculture that is on the global
pedestal currently with a lot of people
who want to control the narrative in a
negative light the the reality is you
cried out of happiness of the national
exposure to Nightline but it's actually
what you're trying to fight against this
is what the funny thing is this whole
game is you know we are in such a macro
framework that you view that as a good
thing because you understand the
benefits of the national exposure you
have no post-production control like you
know I'm sure some I assume at some
level you're aware of me which means you
understand that I'm highly prolific and
putting out creative and I'm known yet I
spend almost no time getting mainstream
media attention I didn't even like the
Business Insider article that was
written that was a pro peace for
vaynermedia because I don't control the
narrative and Kristin LEM Cal gave a
45-minute interview that was glowing and
they took one half of a sentence to show
a hedge cuz anybody who writes an
article about a company has to show some
negativity so it doesn't look like a
press release thus I didn't even read it
didn't even read it so a couple things
great news you do have the control the
question is do you have the patience you
know one of things I'm most excited
about if you follow me on Instagram is
I'm getting to show these videos from 8
and 10 years ago where
saying the same [ __ ] and so when I
pontificate to you guys patience it's
one thing when I say it now and you hear
it and you're like easy for you to say
except I actually lived it you can't
rely on the local community not because
of anything other than that's just not
how the internet works one person shares
one thing on one piece of platform and
it gets picked up in Russia and then the
nature of communication on the Internet
is not localized it is inherently viral
if it speaks the truth what you need to
do if you have this mission accomplished
is worry about your actions not anybody
else's the biggest problem in our
society right now is everybody worries
about everybody's actions but their own
on every side of the equation so what I
would tell you to do is what I'm doing
for a living
which is I have all I have unbelievable
social wants of kindness for the world
but I'm not gonna allow my friends to
tell me how to do that my friends tell
me I need to be a keyboard water warrior
on Twitter I think they're full of [ __ ]
and trying to look good on social media
but don't live their truth in action
meaning continue to your podcast
continue to put out content continue to
work wear your t-shirt but not worry
about what anybody else is doing with it
because when you try to boil the ocean
you don't when you're going to put your
town on the map as such a young woman
you're gonna lose because putting your
town on the map is going to take you 54
years
right so that's that's how I think about
it and not that Nightline is bad but you
need to be thoughtful of like what your
set like the way you're framing it is
right the concern I have for you and
every other human is lack of patience
and ideology over practicality welcome I
was 31 when I started investing I didn't
know I was investing
I just took money out of my bank and
gave it to Mark Zuckerberg parents like
literally like that's the truth like I
didn't think about my Facebook Tumblr
and Twitter investment as I was an
investor I thought of them as I mean
this point in my life I'm a hundred
percent positive these three platforms
are gonna be big and if I put money and
now it's likely that I'll be worth more
money later I didn't even understand IPO
bro if I knew that you could carry other
people's money
what carrying means is I take a million
dollars from somebody who has it and I
invest in the Twitter and I get 20% of
the upside after they get their million
dollars back I'd probably own the Jets
today
that's how positive I was about those
three platforms but I didn't even have
any education of what investing was so I
only wrote my own personal money instead
of going to all my rich wine customers I
would have probably raised 25 million I
would've got 20% if I got five million
dollars and invested into Facebook and
got 20% of the carry it would have been
100 million dollars so like I so that's
one context point today today the answer
to that question is 100% based on the
person I am no longer interested in an
idea I don't want to hate the idea I
don't hate it but I now after 10 years
see the patterns which is this is
singularly for me a game about people
with you said this on your answered my
account talking about like the the weed
bubbles similar to the crypto bubble and
the she and he that I think knows what
the [ __ ] is going on and knows how to
adjust and waits a decade to win versus
the 99.999% of people who are infusing
CBD into products and thinking that's
some magic [ __ ] pill hey Gary I have a
CBD cocoa I'm like cool they think the
CBD part is the magic pill they don't
realize it's the commodity everybody's
doing that right now everything
everything is CBD infused less less cuz
now there's the time of danger because
everyone's in it so you have to be more
thoughtful this is the great year of
Joker's in crypto and and cannabis yet
seven of them are the Meg Whitman's
seven of them or the Mark Zuckerberg the
problem is they're seven million they
get through four years ago there was
800,000 of them and the same seven were
there now there's seven million of them
and the same seven are there that's the
problem got it
gold rushes are dangerous most people
lost money
he has grown from two to eight hundred
people in the past ten years there's
more cynicism from people because
they're less close to me you'll
appreciate this I don't even think of it
as control I think of it as if fifty
nine people in the company and I'm
around them all the time
they have a better read of what I'm up
to there's a very big difference about
between the way team garyvee feels about
me versus LIC producers not because
they're on team garyvee it's that
because they're closer dustin thought
didn't like me the first three months
he's not here but like dustin didn't
like me but he like there's a
conversation we had because he by nature
is cynical there was a couple people on
team gary be that were ready to leave
team gary vee that were up to their own
agenda so they were burning bridges and
he was affected by that and and if he
was a veiner employee he would stay that
way because what Dustin had by being
around is just a luxury to see a play
out my intuition on that is that there's
a small percentage of people in this
company who think I don't care about the
company or I'm not involved because they
think I'm spending all my time being
Gary B that would be the only case and
that and that's probably three to twelve
percent of the people within their first
year to two years or there's just
inherent in people who just like the
idea of fighting against the company
you know there's that's just the way
life is and that's okay I deploy
enormous amounts of empathy against all
of this but it's changed because
everything changes it's like anything
else
but I think the spirit and the intent is
a hundred percent intact which is why
even at eight hundred fifty it feels a
lot better than other places that are
even fifty it's not people like people
are so basic they think size destroys it
intent destroys it there's plenty of
thirty eight person companies that suck
[ __ ] because she or he is about their
money not about their employees
not super complicated so just natural
stuff that I'm super signed up for you
know I don't like being judged
negatively that way by my own team but
I'm empathetic you know you try to do
open door policy try to do things like
this but you know the realities are
there's collateral damage and anything
that is growing as long as I put my head
on my pillow every night it makes
everything pretty easy and I look at
data how much voluntary exiting do we
have here how many people want to come
back after they leave what you know I
don't look at fake data like Glassdoor
I look at real data to this day there's
not a single person that gets fired from
vaynermedia without me personally
approving it that's all you need to know
about this company like I'm so petrified
to do the wrong thing that I need that I
have that employee think about that like
and just to give you guys context which
you wouldn't maybe know is I give
uncomfortable amounts of autonomy to
leadership in this company yet to be
fired here it has to get signed off by
me so you know yeah I mean it's intent
yeah and like and we're wrong sometimes
but we don't value money enough that it
makes us right more often than wrong
because we're willing to spend the extra
three six nine twelve weeks to really
look under the hood to make sure we feel
good about the decision I've heard make
sense and I think we're recognizing what
the upside but also recognizing the
downsides these companies are talking
about things
they know the technology's addictive we
know the technology addictive all that
and we see a lot of people that are like
kind of like wanting to detox sometimes
so how do you think like what is the
evolution of social media look like in
that regard like companies understanding
that maybe people don't want to always
be connected and people not always want
to be connected but understanding that
like social media is not going away what
does that whole evolution look like
accountability if you even for a second
think it's a good idea for Apple and
Google and Facebook to help you be less
addicted you are on the path of losing
you don't like Instagram delete it the
second we allow ourselves to let the
machines help us help ourselves is a
second you become more vulnerable
I believe that sure like you want Apple
to limit the amount of time you're on
Instagram for you like you think that's
the way that's that's what if you want
that mazelTov take it but like I promise
you then there's going to be the next
thing and the next thing and the next
thing you're either account social media
is exposing us it's not changing us
there is no social media brother there
empty [ __ ] pipes social media doesn't
make you mean social media doesn't make
you insecure you're insecure you're mean
we're getting exposed not changed we're
addicted to we're addicted to human
interaction the reason the world exists
in a world where we've had atomic bombs
for 70 years is we like each other we're
not addicted to social media we are
interactive creatures you're addicted to
people cool you don't want to be on
Instagram
go read vogue knock yourself out this is
a this is a very fun thing for me to
watch above people don't like being held
accountable
so a lot of things the way that these
platforms claim they're addictive is the
way a lot of things are addictive are we
gonna ban pretty people are we gonna
limit our time to watching comedy or are
we gonna limit the time we listen to
music this is a really this is the
Luminess it bless you this is the
demonization of technology let me give
you a really good piece of advice go
read the articles around the
Kaleidoscope I'm being dead serious go
google the early articles around the
Kaleidoscope you'll think you're reading
about instagram histories got all the
answers i failed i could not be in this
program because i failed all my classes
but the one class i was good at was
history and it is the continuous
framework of how i think about a lot of
this stuff literally the articles of the
Kaleidoscope are making the same
arguments now so if you have FOMO it's
because you have levels have been
security that are raging which has a lot
more to do with the way you were
parented and where you grew up and the
natural DNA you were given not snapchat
so how do I think it's gonna play out
and its worst our government gets
disproportionately involved which will
be fine I could care less just so
everybody knows I care about attention
not social media so if we all stop doing
social media I'm gonna figure out where
your eyes and ears are going you're
gonna go somewhere we're not locking
ourselves up in a room so I don't give a
[ __ ]
Google and Facebook and Twitter and
Instagram and snapchat and tick tock and
LinkedIn can disappear off the face of
the earth tomorrow and I'd probably be
the single happiest person because my
most comfortable state is reacting
quickly to where attention goes I just
feel bad for any human being that thinks
that's going to help them because
they're gonna find something else to
complain about or to be controlled by
this is an internal frame or a
conversation not an external technology
conversation
the people that leave comments in my
content I consume nothing I literally
have no idea what's going on other than
if it's serendipitously hits my radar
through my own community
I'm just consuming how people are
reacting to what I'm focused on and I
think that's going to keep strength of
mine and you know you get it for example
because I did consume a lot of Richard
Pryor and Chris Rock and Eddie Murphy as
a kid I completely believe the way I
give keynote speeches has an underlining
tone of a comedy routine more than just
like the classic keynote which is why I
think it's worked for me because there's
a level of entertainment that comes
along when I give keynotes so I've
become a character I've been I've been
affected by them in the way that I act I
think the reason my voice is resonating
is I'm not affected by anybody else
right now I'm only affected by the way
people are reacting to me which allows
me to continue to build in the purity of
human truths without blending and trying
to be like
[Music]
you'll appreciate this real quick on
that front just to jump in I'll let you
finish I give zero thoughts to
controlling my public image zero I mean
they dock my teams in here I don't even
look at what they're making the way I
control my public image is by living my
truth and letting the chips fall it's
the most liberating thing of all time I
don't think about it at all
keep going health health health keeps me
up at night the health and well-being of
the 12 people that I'm closest related
to or love the most as a friend scares
the [ __ ] out of me like way more than it
scares most people I think about it all
the time because I don't care about the
work enough like it's what my passion is
but like it's like it's a core 12 person
in my life is terminally ill or passes
away it will shut me down so that keeps
me up professionally I'm not kept up I'm
capable I'm talented business is tricky
because we haven't we don't treat
business the way we treat music artists
and athletes but I think it's much more
similar to that than it is other things
so like once you know you're a good
athlete like you may not win every game
but like LeBrons not confused that he's
bad you know he doesn't think like
tomorrow he's not gonna be able to play
he may not win every game and I
genuinely feel like on that like I'm not
gonna miraculously tomorrow not be what
I've been for the last 38 years of my
life which is a disproportionately
successful business human right so I'm
good yeah I am so sorry I didn't get to
say hello I didn't know I completely
blamed Alex Klein
who is it what you please go around it I
don't know how many are on the phone but
please say hello go ahead awesome let's
go ahead I hope they do it it will
change a lot of people's creative
because they won't pander to likes
they'll start putting out more of what
they want to actually put out it will
make a very high percentage of people
lose leverage because their social
equity is predicated on their following
count and I think it would lead to good
behavior zero zero zero
I'm not predicated on my following count
or my blue check or how many likes a
post gets I'm predicated on the message
I'm delivering in the content you're
welcome
and basically the article said people on
tech talk it's like their likes are like
their value their legs are their money
their legs are they're like it's the
currency it would be the world we all
have always lived in let me tell you
what likes were in 1984 your popularity
ranked in your high school
this is human behavior yes 100% I think
that this company is a complete and
utter reflection of the way I was
parented and the circumstances in which
I was parented 100% I think that this
company is optimistically practical so
and that's uniquely what I can bring to
the table in this company so this
company's extremely young and coastal
which means it's unbelievably socially
liberal which is incredible because I am
as well but that also leads to
vulnerability and so my practicality and
immigrant upbringing and like
merit-based infrastructure helps us a
lot when the most senior leaders do
things that are currently popular but
are unbelievably scary to me of what
that can lead to a month later I mean
like I mean slack at vaynermedia is like
dark reddit like you know like there's a
lot of good but there's plenty of dark
and like that's just the nature of what
happens especially when what's happening
outside the four walls of vaynermedia is
happening in our society which is
activating people in a completely
different way than a decade ago or two
decades ago or two decades from today
and so yes I feel like I'm very
fortunate to be the human that I am
doing
this time because I think I have
practical optimism I'm a Jets fan
because in August of 1982 when I moved
to Edison New Jersey what eight what
1982 kids did was you went outside and
randomly walked around and in one of
those walking around I found three kids
throwing a nerf football and a kid by
the name of Eric Godfrey he looked me
dead in the face and said who do you
like I don't recall what happens next
but I remember who do you like in
football but basically he's like well
we're jet bans so you're a Jets fan and
that September I started watching the
Jets and I haven't stopped that is it
that is the story I'm curious what you
said earlier about tasty tasty things in
your 20s
yes where would you say is the best spot
to do that is it at a company is it in
college is it it's definitely not in
college taking the trip to Argentina or
something or like it's anything but
college only because it's not not and
not to like overly razzing college but
it's a fake environment there's nothing
about college that has anything to do
with your professional career
so not college but then anything in the
real world you know in a company that
has flexibility to let you do a lot of
different disciplines something I'm
proud of that we have here and I'm sure
others do I believe I believe the
framework of the world is backwards I
think that everybody in their 20s should
be at their highest risk behavior and I
think most of you are feeling pressure
on the other side to start being more
responsible in real life that we've
created this narrative that you like
[ __ ] around for four years in college
and it's your last great thing and then
in May of when you're 22 you now need to
get serious and everything becomes super
practical both as a macro thing a level
of underlining pressure we feel from our
parents and underlining pressure we feel
from ourselves to prove that we are what
we think we are and I think that
unfortunately I'm trying to figure out
through my communication then hopefully
that influences others to start a debate
I think the right model is actually that
20 to 30 should be ludicrous
should be all the most extreme versions
of like four different countries 19
different jobs that you have that you
have the ability still at that point to
have the humility to live shitty which
then gives you the luxury to be able to
taste when you're 36 you now have
created overhead in family home car
loans mortgages and other things that
give you less flexibility when you're 22
it still seems feasible to live with
five other girls in a two-bedroom
apartment where everyone's trying to
figure out their world and then college
you don't because I don't believe prop
I don't like college for the value prop
for a big percentage of people I think
college works for somebody left a
comment yesterday on my Instagram that
like guarantee you convinced me to stay
in school and I was pumped and and I was
like yes this kid is hearing me
I'm not [ __ ] on college I'm
cheerleading for self awareness there's
no such thing as one thing works for
everyone this and one of the scariest
things insists in American society one
of the scariest things is parents
putting pressure on kids to go to school
to make the parent feel good and making
the kid take on debt for that when the
kid doesn't feel like they want to do
that and then they come out the other
side and they literally spend the next
15 years trying to reconcile that debt
that's why you have a lot of unhappy
people and then what that means is then
they go yeah I'm gonna vote for the
person that's gonna wipe out college
debt right because that's your
short-term issue just like other people
vote to the Republican side on their
short term issue which then leads to
accountability issues which leads into
people like Google needs to take care of
me this is how the machines are gonna
win you understand that right
I don't want the machines to win I want
all of you to think every single thing
is your fault without judging yourself
into depression which you know
everything's your fault that's a great
thing means you're in control let's go
like which specific thing I want to do
would you say to like start at like some
company first and then kind of figure it
out from there or just like kind of go
how do you learn I think mostly by doing
so done don't go to a company but I feel
like there's a lot of there's a lot of
like I guess pressure in a sense to like
you know you can stop this sentence
right there you know you that you learn
that way but you're gonna do something
else based on somebody else that's
that's what everyone's doing bro and so
everyone's sitting around and trying to
figure out why everybody every all these
young people are so upset
it's because of all this cuz they were
over coddled by a generation of over
coddling parents and they don't know how
to [ __ ] do their own [ __ ] and I think
they could do tons of [ __ ] and believe
you can do so much as long as you tune
out
are you in a place where you're
comfortable to do what I lived through
this is I mean I lived it I lived the
world where from you know now on me but
26 year old me was ringing up my friends
from high school at my dad's liquor
store when they rolled in with their BMW
because they went to a good school and
started working at Goldman Sachs and
could afford one or not really but they
wanted to look like they could and they
were buying a case of Moet Chandon and I
was ringing it up for them and this is
real stories now and carrying the case
to their car and putting it in their
trunk I walked in feeling fulfilled
because I was happy I made a sale they
were leaving they're feeling
unbelievable because Gary's bringing out
my case the problem was that was just
when we were 26 now that we're 43 it's
real real real different I just had the
internal strength to deal with that
scenario 99% of you aren't
how [ __ ] great do you feel at the end
of the day really [ __ ] great mainly
though but I felt really really great at
24 when I slept that case into my
friend's car because I loved process not
not winning I actually like losing more
than winning I've come to learn this is
something I'm really trying to reconcile
I actually like losing more than winning
it speaks volumes to why I'm obsessed
with the Jets and Knicks and completely
of abandoning yet the Yankees and the
Rangers after they want a championship I
like losing more micro losing but Mike
but everything is micro losing besides
death or bankruptcy yep like I just
don't give a [ __ ] what you guys think
and that goes from you all the way up to
my parents that by recognizing that you
guys don't have that nor my parents has
all the context nobody fully knows you
it's actually through empathy early
early like I can't believe how I now
understanding a little bit more back to
like being in your own cocoon I don't I
can't believe the mentality I brought
into high school like to navigate high
school the way I did which is like
completely and utterly not affected by
peer pressure
in hindsight is wild to me that takes a
level of like self confidence at such an
early age that I think I just understand
so much more of what I am now really on
that window because that is such a tough
spot and do you attribute that to
and the work from a young age er yes DNA
my parents gave me clearly the way that
my mother raised me having to earn my
keep
and then just like DNA man just like
that voice that we all have like I just
always felt that I was better and here's
where it gets really good but if the
world showed me I wasn't like I remember
going through this is actually
interesting I don't know if I've ever
shared this I remember vividly going
through the ages of like seven to like
16 being stunned
anytime I didn't win in something like
shocked like just could not believe that
Rick was better at tennis or John just
beat me in one-on-one or I wasn't the
fastest in my class or like just shocked
and you know and I've been thinking
about that lately because I just it
sparked in me a few months ago like wait
a minute that was weird what was that
because I you know just kind of
remembered it like shut I remember
actually what seemed in my mind as a
disappointing thing at the time and now
I look as a great thing
I remember thinking somewhere around 13
14 15 that I lost my expectation of
always winning in everything every time
and I remember thinking like that wasn't
good but in hindsight I think it was
great because the reality is I got into
this place of complete and other utter
confidence but being able to not come up
with excuses if it didn't work out like
watching people like lose and then blame
the Sun like literally like what like I
overheard it a couple of weeks ago
somewhere I was walking and like like oh
I'm on vacation I ever heard it like
this kid lost to his cousin it seemed to
me they didn't look like brothers and he
was blaming the Sun and it took
everything I had to not like roll in and
be like bro I love you but like you need
to realize like the Sun was there for
him too and I think I think a lot about
that accountability like if you're
coming up with excuses like being super
confident filled with excuses when it
doesn't work out is called delusion
so I feel great because I love process I
want to be the greatest entrepreneur of
all time by reframing what an
entrepreneur is and so I probably have
like a very ideological point of view on
you know was crazy when you just said
obviously leave a successful business
and it was funny like how my chemicals
reacted which was like not really you
know like I'm into it I love it it's my
sport it's also why a garage sale right
like I just like the game so sure but if
you read my DMS for a day you'd
understand that way more evolved into
that and I think people are sensing it
to your point and I just want to leave a
positive impact look I think I have a
charisma a communication level that
allows me to have impact right and I
think when one is gifted with that
extreme of that capability they can go
one of two ways and I'd like to go the
way that history tends to look positive
on not negative I'm gonna leave a lot of
money on the table and a lot of personal
gain for really nice reputation when I
can't even taste it because I'll be gone
I want two days of trending on Twitter
not two hours
I do thing of it I feel like your
business isn't everything is always like
growing and moving forward and looking
into the future and like what's the next
thing so is there ever like or is it
like my definition of success for me is
to be able to do what I want to do at
all times always and be happy about it
having freedom is everything no but I
don't think I was I didn't realize what
was going on in my youth you know what I
mean yeah so no I wasn't you know it's
hard for you to really know yourself
completely at this point you'll look
back and realize it was all the same
[ __ ] by articulating it takes time
within yourself and also just takes time
of you actually executing on it back to
like the sub context of what we're
talking about here one of my biggest
problems right now like everybody who's
trying to make positive impact is
they're doing semantical work not actual
work right they're jockeying for their
personal reputation by what they wear or
what hash tag they use not necessarily
what they're actually doing and if they
actually ask them once they actually
embrace the fact that they're being
selfish then they can become selfless
when they're posturing to selflessness
and disguising it their true selfishness
they're losing because that will play
out and that is the boner ability of
being over woke you know that's the
vulnerability and and and and these are
in the reason I like saying them out
loud is because people aren't saying
that part out loud which then doesn't
allow a lot of this good to actually be
effective and then it starts getting
into delusion there's so much I love
about you know making the world a better
place but it has to be practical like
like I would be thrilled if the
government decides to wipe out all these
college debts but let me promise you
what the reaction to that it's gonna be
even worse behavior watch what the 27
year old does when you take 230 off her
bill like watch what she then does for
next 20 years it's not gonna be as good
as people think
recognising that there's always gonna be
some
like whichever one you do like you have
to know yourself so what what I know
about myself is I don't have micro
regret behavior maybe when I'm much much
much older it will kick in because I'll
run out of time but having time in front
of me doesn't allow me to dwell or
regret other people I'm watching here
are 24 and a regreting [ __ ] already I'm
like okay I need to help them think
about this because that's a bad
framework because if you regret if
you're that insecure if you're that if
that's your perspective then you have no
right answer because if you go and
travel and you're 34 you whatever you
are financially or professionally in 30
40 you like [ __ ] I should have
worked more [ __ ] Argentina if if you
know or if you do the other thing and
you work your face off
you be like [ __ ] I ended up just like
[ __ ] Gary all my friends had fun and
yeah I got a million bucks to the bank
but I'm sad because I wish I went to the
[ __ ] beach more often so so either
you're in that framework or you're not
which is which is a great way to put a
bow on everything I've been telling you
you want to blame other people the
government Google knock yourself out
you will go to the grave blaming
somebody for something you want to
understand that even if you're in the
worst circumstances the hood drug
parents super triple minority
transvestite you know trans you know
minority brown like everything
quote-unquote stacked against you but
the reality of actually an Internet
centric world means you have a lot more
control than our grandparents did it
becomes an interesting game your full
control of your podcast let me tell you
about your podcast in 1984 it's not
getting put on the air this internet
thing is going to this is gonna be a
circle guys this internet thing was so
[ __ ] amazing in 2000 2010 now we're
saying this thing is bad what was me too
much power it's bad right the extreme
left is saying like we're not in good
that we need to limit these countries
the extreme rights like you're censoring
conservative this is and guess what
when you guys are 42 we're gonna be back
- this thing is great this is what got
us out of the dark era cuz the good came
I'm just right down the middle not
giving a [ __ ] about anybody else's
opinions or signals or noise because I
know it's selfish in nature I'm doing my
thing trying to be good with this
framework of guilt and gratitude of my
circumstances that put me in my position
I'm trying to give back more than I take
as a legacy 5149 and some of the other
should I talk about and if I [ __ ] up now
be just fine - cuz you were all gonna
[ __ ] up - that's what I'm gonna do
thanks for your time yes
no no definitely since you didn't ask
one go that's okay
you need to figure out who you're most
upset about losing in front of that's
great then you need to start really
thinking about creating behavior to make
yourself lose more you basically are in
the same place that a slow maturing 11
year old is who hasn't started swimming
yet the only answer to your question is
to jump in the pool if you were like my
younger sister I would tell you that
everything you should do for the next 5
years
are things that you're likely going to
lose that until it becomes so numb that
it changes your relationship with losing
losing hating to lose in the way that
you're describing it is completely
predicated on not being able to deal
with other people's judgment and that is
a tough spot to be in you know
you've got to reconcile that with I'm
probably the most competitive person
I've ever met or just in the mix with
the other people so I'm trying to win I
don't want to lose but I respect the
game enough to accept it and i weirdly
get good tingles from it because it
excites me to try again you know like is
is that how your relationship is it with
it or what's your relationship with it
doing of course but why
wasting time wasting resources mm-hmm
well that it goes to the other word I
love so much
you lack patience and or and or the
biggest thing that kids struggle with
contextualizing time if there was out of
all the things we talked about if I my
parting shot I can inject something into
you it would be one thing for you to
feel the way I feel right now about 43
years old when I was 22 and I started
working my dad's liquor store my cousin
Bobby worked there
who's my dad's first cousin but my
grandma was older than their punch line
was he was only eight years older than
me because was like kind of that like
skip generation kind of things with like
older siblings he was 30 when I walked
in that first day at 22 and I'd worked
with him since I was 14 but like when it
became real I'm like I'm a professional
now and we just spent a lot of time
together best friends right like 15
hours a day in a liquor store together
small ones like every day right I
thought he was so [ __ ] old I thought
that [ __ ] was so old so sitting
in this room right now knowing how you
feel about 43 at 20 21 22 it makes me
laugh because like I could literally
like how old are you great
my mom was 41 when I was 21 I'm 43 like
like if I was from the old country
there's a great chance that I could be
your dad you know like I come into here
and I'm like I'm older brother right but
like it's like now getting into like dad
territory meanwhile I feel like I'm
exactly one of you guys on some real
[ __ ] mentally yes
I feel way more similar to you than I do
to 43 year old other person you know
like like like way more I probably know
way more about stuff that's cool than
you guys do by the nature of my business
not because I actually live it but the
punchline is if you knew that if you
actually knew how much more time you had
if you could context how uncomfortably
young you are if you guys could
understand that you're a part of a
generation that means you're gonna live
for for four more full lives from the
day you were [ __ ] born
so right now you're gonna do that four
more times if you can contextualize that
if you could contextualize the blessings
you guys have that you don't live in a
culture where you're expected to be
married at 25 and have a kid of 26 that
there is normal seat created around the
fact you can go and have a 20 year
career and then start your family if you
chemically or intuitively or culturally
or internally want that for yourself we
are being so confused by the macro media
landscape and the political landscape it
has never been a better time to be alive
in the history of the world for
everybody who's being persecuted for
looking different I remind a lot of my
friends to go talk to their
great-grandparents and ask him how it
went for them this is why like this is
why we need to spend more time with
elderly people that are not our
relatives you want equal pay and like
this is that cool go talk to a 63 year
old professional woman like shit's good
and a [ __ ] a lot bad you get to choose
how you look at it not me
not them you and that's how this [ __ ]
plays out
you just haven't contextualized time I'm
yelling at you to waste eight years just
to begin the process of trying to do
something I'm telling you and I know I'm
right
like in my [ __ ] soul that you should
waste the way you see the world eight
years on resources and time just to
start the thesis of what you should do
with your life
and a bunch of you debated heavily if
this was the right internship versus a
different one and like what will happen
and this and that
not a bit [ __ ] matters the second you
understand that you'll never let me tell
you this and I know I'm running late but
we'll be fine
if you actually knew that you would
never find out what the alternative was
[ __ ] would get real good you know how
easy it is for me to make decisions
super easy
do you know why I wouldn't know what the
alternative was because you it's not
practical I don't have time to dwell on
the fact that I passed on uber twice
which is my best friend of any
investment that I made every person I
invested and was not as close to me as
Travis was and for some miraculous
cosmic reason I passed an uber twice
which made up means that my $50,000
investment which would have been worth
700 million dollars today didn't happen
and when I tell you I don't think about
it at all here's why I'm smart and
thoughtful of not knowing how life works
had I made that investment everything
would be different maybe I'd be going to
India to give a keynote about that
investment because I would have much
bigger profile much different resources
and maybe in that private flight maybe
that flight would have gone down and I
would be dead
it's the biggest weakness everyone has
they're trying to spend time on
something that doesn't exist there is no
time machine sorry you picked the wrong
school or sorority or girlfriend or
major
sorry what are we gonna do what we're
gonna build a time machine here cuz it's
both optimistic and way more practical
cuz the punches are the framework
especially if you're [ __ ] on the
offense versus dwelling everything will
work out if you decide everything will
work out it's very real my mom lost her
mom at five she was in the Soviet
[ __ ] Union real communism her dad
then went to jail for a decade that's a
[ __ ] tough hand she's the most
optimistic [ __ ] person I know you're
uncomfortably in control yet this is the
great generation of feeling we're not
googles in control Trump's in control
brexit is in control my parents are in
control you want your parents not have
control stop taking their money it
happens real fast real real real real
real real real fast and all that means
is you just have to live a little more
humble which oh by the way would most
likely lead to much better behavior by
you going forward and a shocking
shocking level of happiness
that's life as I see it at this moment
and it's real you know I really want
this for you guys happiness needs to be
the ambition and you're way more in
control than you think you just have to
stop paying attention to others and
unfortunately the framework is to pay
attention to others which is how this is
all happening
you